ينضم الينا من المنامه المتحدث بسم الله
اسطول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه اهلا بك
معنا سيد هوكينز وابدا معك باخر المعلومات
التي وصلتكم والتي باتت لديكم بشان هذا
الحادث
ياسو فريد
[موسيقى]
خلف هذا الهجوم فقد استخدمت مسيرات ومن
خلال التكنولوجيا التي كانت تنشرها في
المنطقه وتسبب بحاله من عدم الصقر وهو
مصدر قلقا كبير
ليله الامس من شخص وفي حقيقه الامر العام
الماضي وفي شهر يوليو اين همم
مثل احدث سفن وتعرضها للقتل بحجوم مشابه
لدى هذه العمليات لابد ان تتوقف ان نشعر
بالقلق الكبير ولهذا السبب فاننا ملتزمون
بالكامل للحفاظ
على حضور بحرين مستمر مع الشركائنا في
المنطقه في المجال البحريه هل همم هناك ما
يشير الى ضرو حتى رفع حاله تاهب في
المنطقه بحريه على الاقل مع استمرار
الاستهدافات الايرانيه للملاحه
ووهاز
الاكبر متعدده الجنسيات منطقه من حيث
طبيعه شركتها وهي الاكبر في العالم همم
ثلاثه واربعون دوله التزمت بالحفاظ على
القواعد والانظمه المعمول بها في مجال
البحار ولدينا ايضا تحالف اضافي اخر يسمى
همم
الذي يعنى بخطر سوا واحد وهو مؤلف من عشره
دول
منطقه هرمز وباب المنزل
فيما بيننا
المستوى الاقليمي لتلك الشركات وتقديم
الردع المطلوب وكذلك اعاده الطما انا بشان
الشحن التجاري بمعنى اننا ملتزمون بالحفاظ
على حريه الملاحه البحريه
والتجاره العالميه يمكنها ان تسير بصوره
سلسه تلك المنطقه ااه سؤالي لك هل هناك ما
يستدعي رفع حال التاهب
ورد
وعلينا ان نعير انتباها كبيرا لاي انشطه
تزعزع الاستقرار وفي وخاصه في مناطق
المياه المحيطه وهذا ما نفعل وتفعله
البحريه الامريكيه وشركه هنا ولو نظرتهم
الى ما فعلناه في الاسبوع الماضي
المتفجره التي تعدل اكبر من نوعها من همم
مركبات
الامونيوم التي يمكنها ان تصنع متفجرات
فهذا خطر كبير
وكانت عمليه اعتراض مهمه وقمنا بايقافها
لان تلك الانواع
بصوره الغيث شرعيه عبر البحر عبر البحار
وهي غير قانونيه
كبيره خلال العامين الماضي وكذلك ايضا
قمنا بعمليات ضبط تصل قيمتها الى ملايين
الدولارات من المخدرات والاسلحه الكبيره
ومكونات التي يمكن ان تستخدم في صواريخ
التي تطلق على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودوله الامارات العربيه المتحده في مطلعه
العام الحالي
على التحديات والتهديدات التي تعترض
المنطقه
وجلها من بعضها من ايران وسوف نستمر
الاستقرار في المياه الاقليميه همم
التقنيات التي تستخدمها ايران في هذا
المجال خاصه لجهه المسيرات هل تلحظون
تطورا همم فيها همم وبالتالي يستدعي عملا
مضاعفا
اصلا
لمحاوله مواجهتها
تقدما كبيرا في القدرات
الخاصه بايران في ما يتعلقوا بزياده عدد
الصواريخ البالستيه وصواريخ الكروز
والمسيرات الجويه ونحن لم نرى فقط زياده
في حجم القدرات والكميه بالايضا راينا
انتشارا كبيرا لها وتحويلها وتحويل هذه
التكنولوجيا الى وكلاء الاميره هذه
التهديدات بصوره مبكره ولعل هذا يدفعنا
لاختبار قوتنا ومعرفه اين يجب ان تكون
وعلى مقربه من حدوث تلك المخاطر وهذا سوف
يحمل في طياته تاثيرا بدعي وسوف يقوم
بحمايه البحار وهذا هو جوهر تركيزنا في
الفتره الحاليه شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا
الليله على اثر هذه العمليه الايرانيه همم
المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس للبحريه
الامريكيه تم هوكنز من المنامه تحياتنا
اليك